today i am clicking on every single ad
that appears on my channel to see where
it takes us scam product sad life story
i'm watching it baby for years you guys
have been complaining on my channel
about the horrible ads you get today i'm
going to descend among the consumers
turn off adblock and see what i have
subjected you guys to
welcome to a coffeezilla christmas day 9
in the 10 million dollar studio welcome
back guys it starts very simply
check it out just pop open an incognito
tap
go to my channel and let's just start at
the top
remember this fortune yes
the brave
okay what is this
crypto.com
the app
let's learn more because i'm pretty sure
fortune favors the early like people who
knew about crypto in 2013 guys you
learned about it in 2021 i don't know
maybe early probably your karen showing
up with the potato salad 15 minutes late
i mean just gonna be honest preferred
location u.s okay we've got a little
space thing we are a community building
the future of the web
everybody's voting the future okay we
get it powered by cryptocurrency web 3
will be more fair equitable owned by
builders creators and you but not
actually you guys actually them but uh
it'll be fine
get an introductory guide of how to get
started at crypto.com all right it's
just a blockchain company all right i it
could be worse look we start it's fine
not a scam crypto.com is not a scam
right honestly it wasn't even that bad i
don't know what y'all are complaining
about
okay
[Music]
decisions yours to make okay
now i hate myself fa instagram really
skip this ad but i can promise you
what's going on next to america could
change everything you know about making
money if you own regular socks you're in
for a big surprise i spent 50 years on
wall street where i helped create the
entire stock rating system i've met
everyone from jim cramer to martha
stewart but for the first time ever i'm
posting the biggest prediction of my
50-year
mark shakens okay never heard of that
guy i'm sure this is completely legit
career not for the wall street elite but
for you including the name of the number
one investment to buy right now that's a
classic honestly that's a classic saying
i'm doing it for you not the wall street
elite i love that move instead what he
should say is nobody on wall street
would buy the stuff i'm selling so
instead i'm going to you guys who don't
know anything
have you noticed all these financial
advisors all want to help at people
everybody's like just these selfless
guys they just want to help you in short
if you want to be on the right side of
the huge new shift i predict is coming
to the market you absolutely must
consider buying one particular type of
investment now before it's too late and
no what is it cryptocurrencies oh shoot
here i already signed up for crypto.com
okay let's visit the site
okay press play i've been directed hi
i'm tom mustin the man i'm sitting with
here is the creator of one of wall
street's most popular indicators okay
i'm just gonna skip until the part he
actually gets to the point okay i found
it he's selling something called the
power gauge
which is a magical formula that knows
when stocks are gonna go up so all you
have to do is buy low and sell high guys
you could have made a killing on camping
world holdings now obviously these magic
stock systems never really work but i
thought i'd point out that uh marc
jacobs wikipedia page
says uh this article may have been
created or edited in return for
undisclosed payments a violation of
wikipedia's policies and requires some
cleanup because it's not neutral so
i don't know if that tells you anything
but there you go okay next ad we got on
the save the kids story which
incidentally guys if you don't know
about our challenge we're trying to get
to a million subs by december 31st we're
going to give 10 000 to charity or if we
hit it by christmas we're going to give
20 000 to save the children the actual
charity right now we gotta talk about
this ad which we got from an
eight-figure amazon seller guys what
could tom wang the eight-figure amazon
seller want from us the coffeezilla
audience let's watch on a wednesday and
apparently i've sold close to three
thousand dollars in sales on amazon
already now i know what you're asking
tom that's in sales how much money are
you actually making with putting into
your pocket right an average amazon
seller makes anywhere between 30 to 40
profit margin so if your sales let's say
bro if you think jeff bezos has let you
walk out of the door with 40
you got another thing coming dude hey he
didn't even let his ex-wife take that
much okay you think he's gonna let you
take 40 percent mckenzie bezos didn't
even get that so there you go right for
me as well as a lot of amazon fba
sellers as well by the time i roll out
of bed a few hundred dollars has been
deposited into my bank account i get up
i go to kickboxing class i walk my dog
and by dinner time another few hundred
dollars has been added to my bank
account even though the money is good
the best part of this is that you get
your time back selling the dream here
sell it beautiful okay but the question
is if you could do it why do you sell a
course in this training you'll get a
step-by-step tutorial on how to get
started and a crystal clear idea on the
front end work you need to do it's 100
for free it's 50 minutes of pure gold
content bra it's never 100 free okay but
you know we're gonna click the link and
find out how much it is okay after
giving him my email uh we can watch this
video where he'll eventually offer us to
book our private breakthrough call where
he will sell us a what looks like a
thousand dollar course there you go
that's what 100 free means now guys all
right well it's good to know that the
gurus are still advertising on my
channel even after i asked google to not
play get rich quick ads during my videos
uh that's a setting you can toggle
actually in your settings but um
apparently it didn't work because yeah
the
they're still getting through boys like
they're honestly spending ad dollars on
the most woke audience on youtube to
fiona's flowers business is blooming
hey small business insurance yo we're
getting a state farm ad dude what am i
the super bowl hey this feels good dude
that's nice that's moderate high quality
wait what
now there's skye rizzy things are
getting clearer
i feel free to
does my audience have moderate to severe
plaque
psoriasis it dude i was just feeling
good about myself getting that state
format thinking we're a bunch of you
know uh
insurance owning adults here come to
find out we are all adults some of us
just a little
hey some of us have some problems which
is totally fine you got plaque psoriasis
you're loved okay everything
wow we're just gonna let this play okay
may increase your risk of infections and
lower your ability to fight them before
treatment your doctor should check you
for infections and tuberculosis tell
your doctor i like how they sell this
like sad and important stuff and then it
just like cuts back to the nothing is
everything
wow that's attitude
now is the time to ask your
dermatologist about sky rizzy
moderate to severe plaque
psoriasis
all right here we go last ad already
understand btc and you're already using
coinbase but you're struggling to wrap
your head around if d5 nfts and the rest
of this space whether you're in it for
the tech or you're here to take
advantage of the largest wealth transfer
event in history bankless is the
resource that you need say no more fam i
got you okay i guess they just want my
email the ultimate guide to defy nft's
ethereum and bitcoin join 120 000 others
on the bankless journey they call
themselves the ultimate guide to crypto
finance five actionable newsletters
every week or practical
okay whatever why are you advertising to
us are they just making money from
selling their lists i have no idea i
have no idea who these people are i
think if i've learned anything it's that
uh the coffeezilla audience is extremely
targeted by
a lot you know hey
i'll say it nicely uh a lot of crypto
platforms a lot of uh well i'd say
normal ads you know we had some normal
ads in there some cool ads and we had
some definitely scam ads but frankly i'm
not too worried about you guys i think
our audience is definitely more
skeptical than your average
consumer about uh people promising you
to to get rich to make you rich off the
greatest wealth transfer in human
history whatever buzzword buzzword so
i'm not worried but
i did want to come down
from my high horse from my ad block
privileged life come descend and live
among you guys for a bit so i knew what
you guys were going through just bear in
mind i've tried to stop it so i guess
what i'm saying is you guys are right
there are definitely a lot of scam ads
but either way that's basically it thank
you for watching and i will see you
tomorrow in dayton of a coffee still
christmas
this part of the story